how do you stay engaged and
and up on the news and still
keep your wits about you like how do you
keep your mental health in check
while the world is seems to be falling
apart
don't watch the news all day every day i
don't think
our brains are designed to really take
that much stimulus
over and over and over this is how i
feel about twitter even though i am
on it more than i should be if you look
at your replies i bet you if you look at
your applies even if they're positive
it's really overwhelming i don't think
we're supposed to get
that much information that much
communication that much feedback from
that many people
at a in like such a short period of
period of time
you don't think that was happening in
the state of nature where you say
something on the campfire and then all
of a sudden like
hundreds of people step out and start
telling you
with their opinions only yeah people are
caught tweeting you to dunk on you
no that did not happen this is all
completely new
and i agree with you about there being
an optimal amount of news and social
media to consume in a given day
uh i've been so i i'm on cnn
uh and cnn has 24 hours of news uh but i
grew up in a time when there was
approximately 30 minutes of news
[Laughter]
it was like just and here's your nightly
news and we'll do it again like the
local version
and whatnot and i'm convinced that
there's an optimal
amount of news that significantly less
than 24 hours uh
because because the fact is
if i have hours of bandwidth of content
to
fill then i'll talk about something you
know and and i'll try and make it
interesting
um and i'll jin up emotional responses
to whatever the heck i'm talking about
uh and that that's a and social media is
that
compounded uh and you'll write that
right so i'm
i'm very much on twitter um and it was
part of my presidential campaign so it
was very
uh it was very high utility
uh and it continues to be high utility
because i feel like it's
my responsibility and i feel i think you
you and emily
clearly feel similarly where it's my
responsibility to try and put some
positive
sentiments or ideas uh out there because
people
kind of turn to me for a sense of uplift
and you know i'm very touched by that
and i want to
be that uh and you know and and so
it's it's like a function of
who i am now and part of my professional
role
um but occasionally someone in my
twitter feed will be like oh i'm trying
to get off twitter i'm like go
yeah leave i have friends in silicon
valley who could not watch silicon
valley or show on hbo because they said
it just
hit too close to hope they were like
it's too real
you know the first time it it's really
interesting because our show we started
filming
in 2011 i think maybe 2000
don't wait wait what maybe 2013 i forget
but when we when i was doing the pilot
you know it was my judge it was hbo i
told my friends i was like i'm doing
this pilot they're like what was it
what's it about and i said it's called
silicon valley and they were like oh is
it set in the 90s
i'm like no there's crazy [ __ ] going on
in silicon valley right now it's weird
to think
back then we didn't know i mean some
people did but we didn't know who elon
musk was we didn't know who peter thiel
was like people had not heard these
names
now these are household names um
in the six years that we ran or the
seven years that we ran
the way that people look at silicon
valley has changed
so quickly and for me it was a real
wake-up call because i think it was
season two or three
we would sort of do these trips right we
would go to silicon valley and we would
show the episode and we'd sort of like
tour companies and get to see what they
were working on and they were very
excited to have us
because because you know we're we're
doing a show about
about about what they do i was stunned
at what little thought was going into
the moral
and ethical ramifications of the
technology that they were working on
um i remember i won't name the company
but they were
showing us this new product that's now
on the market that many people have and
they were like you do this can do this i
could do this and so we brought up a
privacy
concern and it wasn't they didn't
have they were shocked that they were
asked
this question they didn't even have like
a fake
corporate answer ready to go they were
stunned
and a little upset and disappointed that
we would even think of that i feel like
there's a sense in the tech world and
i'm sure
you know this much better than i do that
technology
is completely amoral uh it's a tool you
make it and how it's used well it's not
up to us well i don't think that's right
i think first of all there's no way that
laws can keep up with technology and i
do think it's the responsibility of
people developing this technology
to consider uh the negative the possible
negative uses for it you know
um i can i mean the the deep fake stuff
all that stuff i
i don't think you can just like keep
developing and close your eyes and ears
to the fact
that these things can be can be really
misused
they're being misused every day in part
because they serve the almighty
marketplace
and we know right now the marketplace
just wants to monetize us and our
attention um whether or not that's good
for democracy
our mental health humanity free will our
ability to come together and solve
problems our ability to settle on
back to the truth uh you know we're all
now uh just
subject to this this uh surveillance
capitalism machine
uh that sells and resells us to the tune
of 200 billion
a year yeah that's what you always hear
where you're like if the app is free
you're the product
and so right now i'm trying to help
people uh wake up to what's going on
with our data
and our privacy rights there's actually
a prop in california in november prop 24
that i'm super excited about
that it's going to create a dedicated
uh data protection agency in the state
of california to look out for california
data and privacy rights which right now
a lot of companies are frankly just
totally abusing and just being like
whatever like
there's no enforcement of course so if
prop 24 passes in november then all of a
sudden
uh the state has to create an
enforcement agency and mechanism
and then you're going to see corporate
behavior change because until there's
until there's actually someone looking
after and then showing up and saying hey
like that there's a problem here
uh so so believe it or not this stuff is
the cutting edge right now this stuff's
literally on the ballot in like a matter
of weeks
good i mean that's the tricky thing you
know if you see like these hearings when
like zuckerberg or any of these folks go
the questions they're being asked it's
it's scary
they're not inspiring it's not inspiring
stuff
about the most basic tech stuff like
it's just
it's it's really upsetting that
um honestly i mean this prop 24
vote yes on prop 24 that's good i'm
gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna
use two twitter to get that word out
because i do think that that
is sort of the big existential crisis
that we're heading towards right now
is is uh is big tech i think
i think it's a formidable foe i feel
like for
all the great stuff that the internet
has done
i think it's it's it's i mean you know
it's it's it's fractured the
conversation
so much to the point where it's not even
a conversation i remember when i was a
computer science major
i would go to my professor's office and
he was this guy he was like a
philosopher
and a computer scientist and he was one
of the
you know original guys who was involved
with the internet and stuff and he had
this quote on his desk from a group of
early people who are sort of trying to
talk about
uh technology and the benefits is going
to provide humanity and he said
something like
the rise of the internet is the promise
of the return of voice
um and i found that so inspiring i was
like that's true
the promise of the internet is i can
talk to someone
in bulgaria you know i can like have a
real conversation with them you really
can connect with people
who have different experiences from you
different perspectives from you see the
world entirely differently and you can
have a conversation with them in reality
what's happened is you just find the
people who exactly agree with you
and then you just talk amongst
yourselves and then you yell at the
other people who disagree with you
so it's really gone in a completely
different direction than i think these
original sort of tech thinkers had
thought had thought it would
um and i i don't know how
i don't know i don't know where we go i
feel like the internet is like this
serpent that we made that's now
swallowing us whole
uh one of my goals uh is to get the
serpent under control camal and like
i may actually have that job uh before
too long
if if things head in a particular
direction i hope they head in a
particular direction
[Laughter]
you know it's funny i was just music to
myself the fact that uh i feel like
you're one of the most
prominent voices in this direction
because of silicon valley which is sort
of ironic because obviously
it you know it was a television show and
yet i feel like everyone identifies you
so closely
with this set of issues in part because
you know we just watched you on hbo uh
for years on end
i know and i'm just saying stuff that
they wrote for me i really shouldn't be
the guy don't look to me for any insight
into it but
but you know we we the the writers and
the creators were very very
i mean they know knew all these ceos
right so
it's all real like you know the fact
that it's like art imitating life or
whatnot plus the fact that you you're
genuinely like a
computer science crowd who worked in the
field for years uh
so i don't know if that helped them cast
you or they're like oh this guy's really
convincing
well no because i was really bad at
computer science i never got it but i
was just
it's funny to go from sitting behind a
row of computers
being the worst guy to then being on set
sitting behind a row of computers and
being the best guy
like i was the only one out of the cast
that like understood a little bit what
the code was
uh so that was a weird experience thank
you for listening in i hope you enjoyed
this conversation
if you did please do subscribe to
yangspeaks and click on notifications so
we can let you know
every time we have a new episode
[Music]
you